broad sense do you get a feeling that so
Britain is heading for a so-called hard
brexit and Labor's powerless to
influence events well I think that was
the signal coming of conservative
conference I think the government have
got to economic policies now at least
two maybe more one from the hard brexit
ears and it seems the prime minister of
saying we should be outside the single
market outside the customs union and
really allowing immigration and the
desire to limit immigration to govern
everything else and then on the other
hand you've got the Chancellor
desperately trying to reassure
international investors that will have
the closest possible trading
relationship with Europe and what we've
seen on the money markets and with the
pound this week is the real world
consequences of that kind of chaos so
what about the second part of the
question labour powerless to affect
issues or is it do you think that
somehow somewhere you can get Theresa
May in the so-called hard brexit ease
before the House of Commons and face
some kind of vote we hear that you're
formally dered Miliband has been talking
to some of those remain as within the
Conservative Party well I think labour
does have an important role to play here
I think we should be speaking up for a
difference really on two counts we
should be saying it's not right that
immigration policy governs everything
else including economic and trade policy
these things should be considered
together not with one ruling the other
and that should mean that we don't begin
this post referendum process by ruling a
membership of the biggest free trade
area in the world what about in the
House of Commons level well I think
there's a strong case for that the
referendum decided one thing which was
that the UK was to leave the European
Union but it didn't decide on the single
market it didn't decide on the customs
union and it didn't decide on a huge
range of other things and wouldn't it be
an enormous irony if in the name of
taking back control and increasing
parliamentary sovereignty the government
decided that after the referendum
Parliament was to play no role
whatsoever in Britain's post referendum
future you know this is a huge question
are we going to be an open outward
looking confident country or are we
going to retreat into right-wing
anti-immigrant nationalism and that I'm
afraid was the signal that came out of
Conservative Party condensed last week
tell me your views on the on the shadow
cabinet reshuffle well clearly there's
been no vote by members of the
parliamentary Labour Party yet on that
issue talk about certain there's been
talk sometime of shadow shadow Calvin
are you part of these discussions part
of these considerations that you'll
ignore what Jeremy Corbyn in its front
bench team saying you kind of take it
your own way no I think there's been in
a way too much internal focus here on
whether the shadow cabinet is elected or
appointed by the leader and so on mr.
Corbin has appointed his frontbench team
I think they have to get on with it now
and to be honest I think the bigger
question for the Labour Party know isn't
how the shadow cabinet is appointed or
elected it is whether we can stop the
country becoming a one party but it's
the policies it put forward because you
know millions of labor vote is
presumably voted for brexit yet we hear
from Jeremy Corbyn did immigration isn't
the problem we'll just give some money
to affected communities now those lack
of voters don't think that well a lot of
labour voters did and I think you've got
to consider these things in their own
data so you have to take concerns about
immigration and the economy together